hi everyone welcome to biology professor
since my last video talking about sort
of popular science and medicine in the
news went so well I thought I would try
to do a few more of these but this time
I decided to pick something that's kind
of a bit of a happy topic but before we
get to it I have to start out with the
bad news which is something you guys
have probably all heard of before which
is the fact that antibiotic resistance
is growing this has been true for
several years in fact I have a video on
antibiotic resistance I did a few years
ago I'll drop a link to it down in the
video description below but there are a
lot of antibiotic resistant bacteria
you've probably heard of things like
MRSA or Mrs a this methicillin-resistant
Staphylococcus aureus there was a point
where that was mainly a nose a komi oula
infection which means hospital-acquired
so people got it when they went into the
hospital for one reason than they would
contract this this sort of super bug
some people call it call it that so
resistant to methicillin and then of
course mrs a became resistant to other
antibiotics as well vancomycin for
example and now it can be acquired out
in the community there's also other
kinds of antibiotic resistant bacteria
things like Clostridium difficile
sometimes called c diff another one
called KP c which is Klebsiella
pneumoniae that has carbon Penna mace
which is an enzyme that makes it
resistant to carbapenem drugs and in
fact a quick google search of the term
pan resistant bacteria that means
bacteria that are resistant to all major
antibiotics turns up a few quite a few
hits things like a pan resistant cre
that's carbapenem resistant and taro
bacteria a CA
there's pan resistant heceta no backdoor
Belmonte I there was a hit about pan
resistant ecoli and more so certainly
we're starting to have infections by
bacteria that we cannot treat with the
antibiotics that we have today at least
not the most common ones so you've got
growing antibiotic resistance which is
not a good thing and then we have
another problem and that's the fact that
the rate of anti pie
discovery is decreasing if you look at
the number of antibiotics that have been
approved for use in humans over the last
several decades the number being
approved over time is going down some
people call this you know the age of
resistance the best the the age that
we're entering I've heard it referred to
many times as the next big health crisis
the World Health Organization has
actually referred to this trend of
antibiotic resistance as quote one of
the biggest threats to global health
security and development today so we do
need new approaches we need new
approaches to discover more antibiotics
to fight these superbugs these pan
resistant bacteria all of these types of
infections that are gaining antibiotic
resistance all the time there's one that
I've been aware of for a few years now
called the I check I'll drop a link to
an article about it in the video
description below but the I chip is this
kind of cool contraption where bacteria
from like the soil or marshes they would
not typically grow on agar plates in a
laboratory can be grown in this kind of
this I chipped technology it's basically
where it has all of these little holes
so you dilute the bacteria sample down
to there's just one bacterium per this
little basically microscopic hole and it
has like membranes around it so that
compounds can get in and out so you can
stick it down in its soil or in its
marshy environment but be able to study
those individual bacteria that would not
grow on just like a regular nutrient
agar plate and so there are antibiotics
that have been discovered that weight
EXO back ten is one that comes to mind
but the main focus of today's video
which I'm finally getting around to is a
BBC news article from February 21st
it's called scientists discover powerful
antibiotic using AI so AI artificial
intelligence I'll put the link in the
video description below but the gist of
it and this is where sort of the good
news comes in scientists have been able
to use this powerful
rhythm to analyze over 100 million
chemical compounds in just a few days
that is absolutely huge I have
experience in a laboratory when I was
earning my PhD working with antibiotics
like chloramphenicol and amphotericin B
and nickim Ison's II and testing them on
different types of pathogens excuse me
and so it certainly took me more than a
matter of a few days so to be able to
use artificial intelligence this this
cool new algorithm to study a hundred
million chemical compounds in just a few
days wild that's so awesome
so scientists used it to find the
compounds that were that we're sort of
estimated or hypothesized to had the
most antibacterial qualities they could
kill a coli and then they selected
around a hundred of those candidates for
physical testing and eventually kind of
discovered the compound Allison I put
that in quotation marks because a quick
look at the Wikipedia page for hallasan
says that it's it's been known before it
was originally being studied for uses
like a diabetes drug but it didn't do
very well so that was sort of tabled for
a while but it turns out that it's
really really antibacterial which is
what this artificial intelligence
algorithm has turned up and so when they
tested it they found that hallasan was
able to kill 35 types of potentially
deadly bacteria and we've got a quote
here from a bio engineer on the team at
MIT james collins who says i think this
is one of the more powerful antibiotics
that has been discovered to date so
that's also really exciting right if
you're going to discover a new
antibiotic you want it to be a good one
when I was working on my PhD I
discovered a new antimicrobial peptide
called temp Oran 1s that um I was the
first one to characterize it and
unfortunately it wasn't very powerful
you know wasn't wasn't wasn't that
effective which was kind of too bad but
in this case they found one not only had
they found this new antibiotic but it's
really good at what it does so that's
great and then the article sums up some
other AI breakthroughs in medicine at
the end for example a drug molecule
discovered by
is going to be used in clinical trials
to treat patients with OCD
another study apparently recently
claimed that AI is more accurate than
doctors in diagnosing breast cancer from
mammograms and so that's great for sort
of the future of medicine to have this
cool new tool I'm not quite sure how I
feel about it all the time I've got a
Google home that frequently tells me
sorry I can't help with that when I add
asked it to add something to the grocery
list or tell me some basic piece of
information and so you know artificial
intelligence is not going to be the may
be the answer to everything right now
but certainly it's come a long way and
is continuing to really push the the
forefront of medicine and that's really
cool so what do you guys think about the
growing problems with antibiotic
resistance is it something that you're
worried about something that you've been
impacted by and then what do you think
about the use of artificial intelligence
there are these new breakthroughs
they're made possible by it do you think
that it's going to be able to replace
humans in the short term or just a great
toolkit to have in our arsenal so let me
know what you think and I look forward
to reading about it in the comments bye